cell division is important for growth
and development of any organism in fact
our life starts with a fertilization
event where sperm is fertilizing the
ovum and successive round of cell
division ensures that growth takes place
and makes us what we are right now but
have you ever entered wondered that how
these sperms and ovum's that means the
gametes which leads to the fertilization
how they are produced it turns out the
sperm and the ovum are produced by a
special type of cell division paradigm
which is known as meiosis it takes place
in the gonads in case of the meal it
takes place in the seminiferous tubules
the germ mother cell give rise to the
gamete in this process similarly for
females it takes place in the ovary and
which give rise to the oocytes and this
process is super important in terms of
creating genetic diversity among the
offsprings that is why we really need to
understand this process and the bits and
pieces and the mechanisms underlying
this process in meiosis DNA replication
takes place once and it follows by two
rounds of chromosome segregation termed
as meiosis one and meiosis two which
ultimately leads to production of four
haploid cells from a diploid mother cell
and these haploid cells are mostly the
gametes and they have some alteration in
terms of third chain and the chromosome
assortment which we would be discussing
in this whole lecture so everything
starts in the interphase just like a
normal cell undergoing mitosis have
have a interface here the charm mother
cells also undergoes interface where
this were in the g1 phase cell
organelles duplicate and starts to
increase in number whereas centrosome
duplication also test takes place in g1
s boundary like mitosis in the first in
first is phase of the mitotic division
DNA replication takes place right and
then what happens in the proof is the
crossing over of chromosomes takes place
crossing over takes place between non
sister chromatids of the homologous
chromosome this crossing ever event
crossing over event is so important in
terms of creating genetic diversity
after that in the metaphase these
chromosomes which are now termed as by
violence or tetrads because they have
now four chromatids they align across
the metaphase plate and microtubules
which are coming from the opposite sides
attached to their kinetochore and they
are ready to be pulled to the both sides
now these by valence actually separates
and migrate towards the pole in the turn
in in the phase of anaphase one of
meiosis one followed by a telophase
event this is pretty quick phase while
the nuclear membrane reappears and the
chromosomes again gets T condensed so
that is the end of meiosis one and after
that mitosis meiosis phase two would
take place in the meiosis stick in the
muse is - or the professor - similar
event takes place but in this phase no
crossing over take place in beyond this
phase these
chromosomes get aligned into the
metaphase plate now the microtubules are
capturing them from both the sides
remember in the metaphase one
they were only captured from one side of
one particular bivalent now here due to
equal tension they are separated from
each other and both migrates towards the
opposite pole in the anaphase ii of
meiosis which ultimately leads to
segregation in telophase 2 and
reappearance of the nucleus in telophase
2 that leads to production of four cells
which are haploid in nature from a jar
mother cell now let's look at the
process in a bit more details the first
phase of the prophase 1 is basically lip
2 team lip 13 stands for thin thread at
this stage the chromosome is actually
individual visualized or it can be
visualized under a microscope just like
a thread that is why this stage is named
so leptin is very short in terms of
duration and in this particular stage
progressive condensation of the
chromosome and the coiling of the
chromosomes takes place just after Ella
protein comes psycho team in zygote in
the chromosomes approximately line up in
two homologous pairs so the we know for
each chromosome for example chromosome
two there would be two homologous pairs
right and these pairs are lining up each
other in a line and they're forming a
prison Aptos or more complex as in
aptana more complex and at the end of
this phase comes back 18 where the key
event is the homologous recombination
and the strand exchange between the two
chromosomes and the strand exchange
takes place between the non sister
chromatids of the two homologous
chromosomes before that before the
exchange takes place
there is a X like structure formed which
is known as the Caius mother or the
Junction this Junction is later on
dissolved in the plotting stage where
the strand exchange is pretty much
complete followed by deploying there is
a small there is a very short phase
which is almost overlapping with the pre
metaphase this is known as star
kindnesses which we are not discussing
here so just to summarize the events of
the my meiotic prophase is like king
left to teen stage the chromosomes start
condensing and becomes individualized in
zygote in chromosomes are aligned in
homologous pairs when pocketing the main
event of crossing over takes place
followed by deep loading where the
chromosomes specially suppressed
exchanged their strands and the crossing
the synaptic zone all complex is
actually degraded now just like a
mitotic prophase in the mute professors
will cyclin b and c DK one takes
important role to phosphorylate nuclear
pores and degrade that not only that the
nucleus is actually supported by the
lamina which are the intermediate
filaments and lambing has specific
domain structure what happens is this
lamin is getting phosphorylated by
cyclin b and cdk1
leads to their dissociation when the
lamins are dissociated the framework the
structural framework is gone it would
ultimately lead to a collapse of the
nuclear membrane that it that is pretty
much common in case of both mitotic and
meiotic prophase and ultimately these
spindle apparatus would move to the
opposite poles because they had to pull
these by valance from from both the
sides now it's important to note the
meal at meiosis 1 and the metaphase 1
the chromosomes are attached
from the both sides of the bivalent but
for each particular chromosome
it is not attaching from both the sides
this whole organization is known as a
tetrad where there are four chromatids
now in anaphase these by violence are
actually separated one is going from one
side of the pole and another is going
other side however in meiosis two in the
metaphase the microtubules are exactly
attached to the opposite side and it is
ensured that equal tension is
experienced in both the sides that is
why when in anaphase two these
microtubules are shortening then the
chromatids are individualized and
separated and pull towards two opposite
poles ultimately it leads to four cells
four haploid cells with a slightly
different genomic on genomic
configuration and that is the basis of
all sort of diversity but have you ever
wondered why meiosis prophase is very
different from mitosis how it evolved
during the evolutionary timeline and why
it is only then selectively towards the
gametes not the somatic cells these kind
of discussions are beyond the scope of
this particular lecture we would be
talking about this kind of discussion
later in some other videos but for now
if you like my video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe and I'm also available in an
academy platform which is India's
largest online learning platform here I
interact live with the people so you can
always join an academy and stick us plus
subscription which is super cheap and
use my referral code ap tend to get a
10% discount I hope to see you in any of
these platforms thanks for listening